let's answer some audience questions got
some good ones this week first is from
Chris Chris says should there be any
censorship of swear words in media the
answer is obviously it depends now the
answer is no I I'm against censorship of
individual words I think that there
should be context and circumstance sort
of used if you're producing a show meant
for little kids it would be great if we
didn't need to have rules like okay
here's seven words you can't use or you
can't describe in the detail these types
of actions that bodily functions or
whatever the case may be it's not
because I think that if a six-year-old
hears the F word or sees Janet Jackson's
nipple like in that infamous Super Bowl
halftime show incident that their lives
are going to be ruined but it seems like
you can reasonably produce a kids show
for example in a way that would be
relatively WorkSafe but as far as you
know I've talked about in Argentina
there's really not the type of oh here's
seven words you can't say in blah blah
blah if you're watching TV and and it's
you know 6 p.m. 7 p.m. whatever
there can be swear words it's just not a
big deal nobody makes a big deal out of
it nobody's lives are ruined period and
I'm sort of against the FCC or regulator
regulatory agencies getting hugely
involved in that now should there be
hardcore pornography on CBS at 9:00 a.m.
no there shouldn't be but the entire
paradigm around seven dirty words and
FCC fines and all that stuff and
basically again and it really just comes
down to children right I know some
people have this heightened sensitivity
when it comes to about hearing certain
language or sexually explicit content or
violent movies also like some some
adults just don't like violent movies
but they can decide not to watch them
also yeah I just don't think those are
good enough reasons you know especially
if you're playing something in context
and it's important to hear the words
that the original source used I think
you should just let it be and to be
super clear I know people every time we
talk about anything even approximating
this issue people will say David you
refuse to use this word or that
word and you believe voicemails we're on
broadcast radio and television so we
have to make the decision as to whether
we want to deliberately break rules
which could could get our broadcast
affiliates in trouble or just abide by
it because we have a relationship of
trust with those affiliates and we're
going to send them stuff that's going to
get them kicked off the air it's not
because of my personal sensitivities
that we were doing that and of course
any TV station can make whatever
policies they want if they'd want to
believe swear words if they don't want
to use a sensitive language like the
n-word or any other kind of derogatory
expression they can go ahead and do that
I think it's more of a question of if
should the FCC be allowed to crack down
on that sir that's exactly right because
while any station can make a decision
they're putting themselves at risk of
being fined and to be clear we have
accidentally sent out some swear words
before where you will be playing a video
clip of something that went on and in
the background there's their swearing
for example or something like that and
we might not notice it and then it goes
out there have been incidents where a
voicemail gets out that has some
language that we shouldn't be sending
out on broadcast radio and TV affiliates
and they don't even notice too sometimes
we don't notice and fortunately
nothing's ever come of it so far but no
I am against the idea of censorship of
swear words I think that we should just
have producers that we say hey you're
adults use the use judgment to decide
whether you should have you know graphic
descriptions of violence in a kid's
cartoon or something like that Romancing
and also it's perfectly acceptable to
show on the news bombs taking off for
example or yeah people are going to end
up dying on the end the other end when
those bombs land but it goes too far to
use certain words well that's wrong on
there is an issue though with the
footage which is in other countries when
you see coverage of wars and armed
conflict the videos that are shown are
way more graphic and in the US we have a
more sanitized version of war reporting
and lo and behold we have typically more
support for military action in the
United States than in other countries
and that's actually a pretty big deal
it's hard to be in support of military
funding when you see those bombs land
rather than just taking off that's
exactly right so that and that's
probably a conversation
broader conversation for another day
good question Chris